customers will be able to speak with
their bank or mortgage lender without it
having an impact on their credit score
they'll also be able to change to an
interest-only mortgage or to extend the
term of their mortgage and go back to
their original deal within six months
also without impacting their credit
score there will also now be a minimum
term of 12 months before a home can be
repossessed without consent let's take a
listen
I just want to say is to everyone who is
worried about the high inflation that we
have in this in this economy at the
moment uh tackling High inflation is the
prime minister and my number one
priority we are absolutely committed to
supporting the bank of England to doing
what it takes we know the pressure that
families are feeling that's why we've
introduced Big support packages around
three thousand pounds for the average
household this year and last but we will
do what it takes and we won't Flinch in
our resolve because we know that getting
rid of high inflation for our economy is
the only way that we can ultimately
relieve pressure on family finances and
on businesses Chancellor that's great
for credit scores and those that the
really hard press but you just had the
biggest names in banking here anyway
saying you've actually agreed nothing
for millions of borrowers who are seeing
their thanks jacks up they will not be
able to afford them well as I said we
agreed some very important things for
people who are worried about their rates
going up not just the people who are in
an extreme situation but the most
significant thing is that they can pick
up the phone to their bank or their
mortgage lender and talk about their
situation without any worry that it will
impact their credit score and if they
decide to make their payments easier by
extending the period of their mortgage
or by going to an interest-only package
they can go back to their original
package without any questions asked
without any impact on their credit score
within six months that's the reassurance
that people like Martin Lewis have been
saying will make a big difference for
families in those situations